60s and as many books on economics he's
interviewed by his biographer Richard
Parker at Harvard University this is
just over an hour tonight it is my very
high privilege and very distinct honor
to introduce Trulia forum for the ages a
forum event with an American legend a
forum event with a true American icon
born in neighboring Canada in nineteen
eight and because he was born in Canada
that's the reason we probably never ran
him for president is someone by the name
of John Kenneth Galbraith who has walked
with kings and queens has become one of
the most influential economists of the
20th century he is authored over 41
books is served as a close advisor to
President Roosevelt Truman Kennedy
Johnson Carter and Clinton and he will
be talking about some of these
individuals during the course of this
conversation with you this afternoon but
perhaps his greatest accomplishment has
been his marriage to Kitty and Kitty we
thank you for sharing once again at the
garden Thank You kitty
Thank You favor interview our special
guest this afternoon is our friend and
my neighbor at Quincy house Professor
Richard Parker
Richard is the author of the forthcoming
book John Kenneth Galbraith the maker of
American economics professor Galbraith
we want to thank you we want to thank
professor Parker both of you for being
here this afternoon and especially
Richard for all of the work and all of
the help that you have been in helping
to arrange for our very distinguished
visitor to come to the Kennedy School of
Government forum this afternoon
professor Richard Parker thank you
Thank You senator Pryor for that very
kind introduction well fear it Harvard
and especially here at the forum I think
it's safe to say that we're quite
familiar with celebrity where I'm
sitting here tonight have stood
presidents and kings movie stars and
Nobel laureates four-star generals and
finance ministers but would do respect
to them all let me say that we here are
less familiar with Fame celebrity in
this age of infotainment and television
touches many it is so often a passing
thing same however touches a few and
unlike celebrity indoors with me tonight
is one of the nation's if not the
world's most famous men John Kenneth
Galbraith his fame fortunately makes my
task easier for it allows me to be brief
more than once professor Galbraith has
said that for a competent Harvard
professor there should be no subject
however large but it cannot be
adequately presented in 50 minutes the
standard length of a Harvard classroom
lecture but professor Galbraith himself
is the living exception to that rule
because in 50 minutes I could barely
begin to list his accomplishments the
senator pryor is noted he's the author
of nearly four dozen books to which I
might add four dozen books which have
sold more than 10 million copies and
three dozen languages in more than 60
countries around the world he has been
not only the president of the American
economics Association but also of the
American Academy of Arts and Letters a
testimony to his range he holds honorary
degrees for more than 50 universities
including Harvard and Oxford curiously
enough not Yale but we will not speak of
that other place this evening
China Kennedy what I meant
mention Moscow and Moscow and Moscow
State University i will also add in lieu
of yale moreover he's been honored by
France with the Legion of Honor by
Canada with its highest civilian award
the Order of Canada
and by India with its highest civilian
award and I might mention here in the
United States he has been given the
nation's highest civilian award the
order of freedom not once but twice the
only American ever to be so honored
during the Second World War at the age
of just 32 he became the nation's price
are in charge of all civilian prices and
thereby the chief manager of America's
wartime economy at war's end he became
director of the Air Force's strategic
bombing survey it is still the most
powerful examination the strategic air
power the country has ever produced
after the war the State Department then
put him in charge of planning the
economic reconstruction of both Germany
and Japan still in his 30s he even found
time to become for several years senior
editor of Fortune magazine where he
introduced America's most powerful
business executives to the ideas of John
Maynard Keynes as well as his own he was
for Adlai Stevenson in 1952 and 1956 a
principal speechwriter and advisor for
President Kennedy of course he was
ambassador to India and much more
personal confidant Sage adviser the
first among Kennedy's inner circle to
see and warn against the folly that
became Vietnam not in 1963 not in 1962
but in 1961 three months after President
Kennedy took office for a time he also
served Lyndon Johnson especially in the
early days of planning the war on
poverty but as the war in Southeast Asia
grew Ken Galvez took up the role of
critic in the center lending his voice
to the campaign's to end the war and
transform the Democratic Party as well
as the country he recruited Eugene
McCarthy to run for president in 1968
and it was at the center of the George
McGovern campaign in 1972 the beginning
in the 1970s men like him found
themselves increasingly isolated in some
cases rebuked richard nixon and later
Ronald Reagan and George Bush claimed
that America was a conservative country
one moreover for the markets and private
wealth had been unfairly fettered in
their natural and rightful power and
rank many fell in line with this new
wisdom that ken Galbraith was not among
them throughout the 1970s and 80s and
90s as in the years before then he
continued to speak and write on behalf
of a richer understanding of America and
its place in the world of our
obligations to the poor and of the
necessity that democracies oppose
entrenched privilege and power wherever
they arose in book after book article
after article speech after speech he
argued not only for the widest and most
generous understanding of democracy as
inclusive and egalitarian but the right
and responsibility of democratic
citizens to direct the economy for
public ends for over he also did it
always with the trademark Galbraith Ian
wit Thomas Carlyle who once pronounced
economics the dismal science clearly
never knew ken Galbraith / Galbraith the
challenge we as Americans still face is
to rise far as is and we have come to
date to be more than a nation of as he
once put it the bland leading the bland
in this economists need to point to more
than optimal the prices for things that
help men and women see beyond the making
and getting of everyday life or in his
words a man who reads Businessweek is
lost to fame one who reads Proust is
marked for greatness this evening with
professor Galbraith were going to
remember a few things from the past but
also talk to some things of the present
and of the future I have no doubt you
are going to enjoy it professor
Galbraith I want to start by asking you
to talk about three American presidents
and their wives men and women you've
known personally Franklin and Eleanor
Roosevelt John and Jacqueline Kennedy
and Lyndon and Lady Bird Johnson and
what they symbolize for you
well I had to recover from my deep
delight in that account of my history
and tell you how much I enjoy being here
and how much I appreciate the comments
of the senator from Arkansas which
causes me to mention one of the great
mysteries of American political life
which is why do all our really good
politicians come from either
Massachusetts or Arkansas other night as
some of you will remember my mind went
back to a hearing some time in the 1940s
or 1950s on the stock market and senator
I got the story wrong that night while I
was testifying the stock market took a
massive slow and I didn't know it but
everybody else did and Senator Fulbright
when it came time for questions said
professor I must say I was devoted to
Fulbright he was one of my closest
friends
he said professor if the stock market
fall cloud of beds was today will be
blamed for it won't we
and I didn't know what was happening I
said if the wall of ensured senator that
would be a short run
but the history historians will forgive
you and us and he said could I remind
you professor that I am up for election
this Holliman not those historians they
have my pleasure in the evening is
modified of course by the extent that
you will have to suffer because like all
people given to personal history I enjoy
hearing of my own from myself Franklin D
Roosevelt and Eleanor Roosevelt have
always been the largest figures the
largest political figures in my life and
the life of my generation I had two
extended encounters with FDR one just
before World War two when I was brought
to the White House for a study of the
relief programs which I conducted for a
couple of years
Alif I was on leave partly from Harvard
and later from Princeton and it was a
lovely experience but I saw very little
of FDR mostly I got encouragement and
one of the great moments of that time
was something that brought a shrewd life
an FDR it was there Warm Springs he was
downstairs there Kenny and I visited it
since and the question came up about the
great relief programs many of which most
of which involved from building and
certainly emphases be as Harry Hopkins
wanted on the work that was provided the
people that needed those job should that
be the basis of decision or should as
Harold Ickes wanted and he had charge of
the building that resulted the
Triborough bridge or whatever was that
that was what historians would celebrate
people would celebrate and that should
be the tale when Harry Hopkins had
finished FDR said Harry you're perfectly
right and in the afternoon when Ickes
came in and made his speech FDR said
Harold you're perfectly right
and Eleanor who had been listening to
these hearings and taking it all in when
they had got both Don said Franklin I
just don't understand you Harrell comes
in here you tell him he's perfectly
right Harry comes in here and you tell
says something totally different and you
tell him he's perfectly right I just
don't understand you Roosevelt thought
that over carefully and said Eleanor
you're perfectly right the principle
relationship I had with FDR was during
the warriors when the Prima Tory early
age I was put in charge of price control
and put in charge of what was my own
initiative the general maximum price
regulation which provided that you could
lower price but not increase it without
government for rezar
and that lasted through the war it
worked we have in World War two no
memory of inflation where in World War
one prices doubled in the course of two
years
and it gave me a very shrewd view I
thought at the time of both the process
of public administration
and the people who are running the
economy I have to tell you a story about
that and then I will get back to
Roosevelt every afternoon we had a
hearing in my rooms of the offices when
somebody came in to get a higher price
was suffering they were business
executives they wore nice blue quotes
and collars a nice blue coats and white
collars sat at a long table with my
staff and I would look down the table as
they made their case it was full
employment but stress strong flows of
orders the best profits since before the
Great Depression and my staff would have
their hands going like this on the table
and from now on it is something you
should remember and you may on occasion
have a lecture at Harvard where you will
need it that refers to the great period
when there was a terrible shortage of
food a terrible drought in head country
affecting an anthill on the side of a
great hill and the queen ant mobilized
the troops to go and look for food and
presently one day
a group of ants that she'd sent out a
detachment came galloping back down the
hill to where this ant colony was
situated halfway down to say that a fine
piece of food horse manure had just been
discovered at the top of the hill and
she will mobilize a force out to bring
it back and it was necessary to hold
against it because the hill was steep
and there was danger that would write
down and be lost so she got more and
more of her troops to hold against it
and she went up and down with her aunt
and I going like this which in ant
language means stop that horseshit and I
would look down my table and my very
reputable staff would be going like this
as as I say that is something which I
gives you you now for all future use
maybe even tonight what question was I
supposed to end I think I know you well
enough that a question to the you was
simply pointed in your direction that
you will that take it where it will lead
Franklin and Eleanor Roosevelt John and
Jacqueline Kennedy blended the lady
birches know they they're both Franklin
Roosevelt and in some one lesser measure
Elinor looked at the United States
looked at all the states as an extension
of Hyde Park for which they had the
responsibilities of the couple the
family in charge not as landlords but
the responsibility for everything on the
estate and he did this in the case of
FDR was a human concern how these people
were surviving and suffering and what
could be done it wasn't an ideological
reaction eleanor was more of a liberal
and this carried her into matters
including race relations voting power
and relief into a deeper commitment than
FDR one consequence of which was that
then and again in the war years when we
had something about which we felt very
high a very high level of urgency we
went to Eleanor rather than the FDR
for two reasons first we had a more
sympathetic audience and second we could
get an appointment ha ha ha ha and over
her lifetime she was my one of my best
love friends and there should be no
doubt that in their humane commitment at
home and abroad that the position of FDR
was enormous he strengthened by the
association he had with Ellen who else
there were half a token the Kennedy well
this is a for me a very different
situation I lived when I first came to
Harvard 1934 believe it or not in winter
house and our two of our most
distinguished residence with the two
Kennedy brothers Joe and the president
the President to be and through them and
through a long association I had with
their father not a long association but
a close one I came to know them very
well and I came particularly to admire
Joe Kennedy one of the tragedies of
American life was that one of the ablest
undergraduates Harvard ever had was lost
during World War two Thea and it was
from that background
that life began with John F Kennedy who
was intelligent attractive and not given
to an excessive amount of work yet he
had that highly cultivated detachment
from labor that Marx
SILS of this day a certain part of the
undergraduate body and from that came
politics from that came support and I
was identified to some extent with his
campaigns for Congress and very much
what the presidential campaign very much
if there was a part of the country where
there was no hope or not much hope of
election but where they had as somebody
who was held to be close to Kennedy I
was sent and I became in that campaign a
real expert on the democratically
hopeless parts the country but there was
there was more because of Kennedy's
father
there was a strong rift between the
Roosevelts and the Kennedys and
mrs. Roosevelt did not come out for
Kennedy when he announced that he was
coming running for president
she was totally detached and even
opposed but she was at that time giving
sub lectures television lectures at
Brandeis and I took on the job of
persuading her that Kennedy was not Joe
and that he was someone she should
support and she finally said this was
the wonderful thing that she would judge
she would make the decision but she
would like first ever Kevin come on our
television program wonderful oh I got
incents with him he came up was New
Year's Day he went on the program and it
went beautifully and there was a huge
press conference afterward and
inevitably the first question was mrs.
Roosevelt does senator Kennedy appearing
here mean that you will be supporting
him for the nomination
she said it certainly does not and that
left the whole program behind or was the
dominant news the next day and that
night Kitty and I went over as we are
often did on a Saturday night to look
over some famous restaurant in those
days for dinner with one or two others
including professor Slater and
[Music]
so first as we sat down Kennedy said you
know something I always thought that it
might happen that there would be
somebody who's a college professor who
would have some grace and ability on
political matters but can you prove it
will never happen they who else the
Texan LBJ he was in some ways the most
misunderstood man we ever had in the
White House I had known him from his
days in Congress and had been a
consistent admirer and subjects of
amusement he was a wonderful companion
and this was helped by the fact that we
were exactly the same age three months
apart and were naturally in Washington
thrown together in the same age vote and
became close friends and with the
passage of time I visited him down Texas
what bird hunting with him one day I
didn't want to admit to him as a Texas
sports one that I had never shot a gun
so I went into my Jeep and he took his
Jeep and I pointed the gun up close my
eyes and fired it the doves in Texas
have never been so safe
and then came Vietnam and this was
something that paired up one of the
ablest political leaders in our history
particularly in his relations with the
Congress at the carriage up his enormous
commitment to the poor and the working
community from which he himself had in
some measure graduated and most
important of all was Lyndon Johnson's
commitment to right to civil equality
and ripe fruit and race relations we
have already to this day for God we have
to this day for God that after Lyndon
Johnson one who go to the South without
knowing that they were without expecting
some sort of upset in a restaurant or in
the back of the bus
this was his not this was his
contribution so far as anybody in
politics could make a contribution and
as they say that was blasted over by the
Vietnam War I had two recollections of
that one is they
wait that riot at Chicago for gene
McCarthy a riotous evening in the parks
and a riotous evening in the convention
I was G's floor manager and I have to
tell you that that was an experience
which I wouldn't recommend to anybody to
be a manager with no one taking her
management is well I know as I say I
don't wish anyone would have the
experience but that was the night I must
say if a personal role that I knew the
Vietnam War was coming to an end because
we took turns going across Michigan
Avenue from the hotel to a mass of
people in the park who were
demonstrating against the war and the
great riots and protecting the hotel
which was the headquarters of both of
the of all the candidates of both
candidates was a line of national
guardsmen and standing shoulder to
shoulder along the front and I went
through them my night got up in a
platform that had been rigged up and
made a report on what we were doing in
organizing against the war
and also my plea that they stay away
from violent action Mayor Daley's
priests are always going to be better at
that than you are and it's just a matter
of common sense to take a peaceful
position and then amenity regretting I
said it I said it I said I don't want
you trying to plug ins with the National
Guardsmen we're standing here behind me
and then immediately I said just keep in
mind their draft dodgers just the same
as you are and immediately knew that I
had said the wrong thing and that was
when I knew the war was coming to an end
that was my closing line and they as I
finished the sergeant who was in charge
came up on the platform and said sir
could I have a word with you and I knew
that I was going to get it he said I
just want to shake your hand cuz that's
the best thing that's been said about us
all day
[Laughter]
and that was my knowledge that the war
we're over
sorry no not at all
your your government service has always
been in support of Democratic presidents
but you've also known some Republicans
as well to Richard Nixon and Ronald
Reagan in particular would you mind
giving us a few words on that
well I didn't know Nixon personally and
the few years ago I went down to give a
lecture to the staff of the National
Archives and they dug up all the adverse
papers that they could find on me which
is what they do for any speaker and made
the discovery that I had not known that
Richard Nixon was on my staff at the
office of Price Administration and had
written my letters and he was on the the
paper facsimile papers that they gave me
I am anything must add on Richard Nixon
because cause me the worst weekend I
ever had on a Saturday we were up in
Vermont he published there was published
the enemies list and I was on it with
two checkmarks and everybody I knew
called up and said how the hell did you
get on that list and I did there was a
mass of gelatin well that's my view of
Richard Nixon Ronald Reagan I never met
it Ronald Reagan and I did know each
other we were both founders of Americans
for democratic action a da
a dominant liberal group of that time
and I knew him partly because he was one
of the avenues of money that came to a
DA from Hollywood which we very much
appreciated
nothing smooths the relationship so much
as a check and then he went out on a
lecture tour for General Electric for
several months and began reading the
material was suggested to him by for the
audiences and came to believe it
unfortunately but it has to be said for
Ronald Reagan as it had to be said for
his voice they had one great virtue they
both enjoyed the job much more than they
concern themselves with the policy and
that was good and
and now in this day and age I could be
one of the very few people in the very
few people with some Democratic Party
tradition who yearns for Ronald Reagan
instead of our present situation you for
many years have been among the most
distinguished students of the British
economist John Maynard Keynes and yet
your works developed your own
distinctive brand of thought that some
have come to call the Galbraith ian's
system would you care to describe for
the audience what you think the elements
the most important elements of the
Galbraith ian's system and economics are
well I I was greatly taken as all my
generation in the 30s the late 30s by
john maynard keynes and went to
cambridge england for a year to study
under him that was the year he had his
first heart attack and i never and he
never came to the university there is no
doubt about the importance of the vision
he gave as to public policy
macroeconomic policy in those days here
at harvard we had two classes of
economists those who were still in the
19th century and very keen to get back
to the 18th
[Applause]
and those who were marked nor marker and
had the established marsh alien view of
the economy with great emphasis on the
role of Monopoly corporate price-fixing
ed Chamberlain's monopolistic
competition
which captured the largest part of the
of the teaching and student position and
then there was a small minority who had
gone on to a solid left position that
was that and they held those of us were
more respectable and more cautious with
a certain discomfort and even this day
this was the mood of Harvard prior to
Cannes with as I say the greatest
emphasis on impairment of the wage price
and the price demand structure the first
book I ever wrote was on that most one
of the most disastrous experiences of my
life it was called modern competition
and business policy and related the
depression to the fact that there were
dominant influences holding up prices
and limiting production in contrast with
agriculture where they where the
production is not controlled or where
there's full employment
and much lower prices and in the spring
of 1937 just as that book went to press
I read Keynes and changed my mind but
the book was had gone depressed and it
got very good reviews from all of the
economists with whom I disagree the
contribution of cases went far beyond
economics incidentally but it was the
first record of overview of
macroeconomic policy imposed on the
government on the state that you
provided that by the state through
employment or through state-sponsored
investment they employment the income
the purchasing power that did not come
from the private sector and that that
was a sweeping view partly because of
his extreme plausibility and those of
you who are here at Harvard should not
be in any doubt it was at Harvard that
those ideas to Harvard that those ideas
came to the United States it was
impossible after 1937 to avoid an
evening seminar on k's and they went
through most of the daytime and if there
was nothing else that you could do you
could go to a meeting with sean Bader to
hear him denounce case
but which he did in a very eloquent way
and this was one of those rare times
when every week somebody some group came
up from Washington from the civil
service to discuss these matters they
came to have an Hansen seminar so that
this was in economics a break point for
a whole generation of which to which I
belong belong moving from old-fashioned
economics including market structures
monopolies and competition to the notion
of a public responsibility for
maintaining the purchasing power they
would keep people keep businesses going
keep people overworked it was a very
interesting time you both had a few
critics within the economics profession
you have had one or two critics within
the economics profession certainly at
the University of Chicago the home of
your good friend Milton Friedman but
there was also another University of
Chicago economist George Stigler who as
I recall on reviewing a book of yours
remarked that too many people were
reading professor Galbraith and not
enough were reading out of Smith do you
happen to recall your reply to professor
Stiegler I said I said I thought the
point was well-taken but incomplete that
they his great tragedy his great sense
was how few people were reading stigma
at all
but I I have a good relationship
yep always an inner relationship with
Milton Friedman because he made me
president the American economics is okay
he was on the board when my name came up
and I I had a majority and he raised her
was nearer majority and Milton raised
them his objection that Galbraith was
not the type of economist that should be
hint of a professional academic
scientific group and developed that
point and his closing comment was that
is keep in mind that Thorstein Veblen
was never had of this organization and
that was so damaging so much cause so
much sense of guilt that I went through
the next five minutes hahaha professor
Galbraith in economics as well as in
politics you've long been associated
with what some today refer to only as
the l-word or when they refer to it at
all talk of it as a thing of the past
what is liberalism mean to you and how
relevant is it to us oh I haven't have
no hesitation on that at all I don't
believe in categories there there's some
matters where you want many matters
where you want to exempt yourself from
doctrine and apply your view in the
particular case most of the of the
results of what of that I suppose caused
me to be called a liberal but it is
practical or what's the one senses to be
the practicable judgment for the
well-being of people it should be the
controlling doctrine and that's what I
try to have so if somebody wants to call
me a liberal I'm prepared to accept it
like it and ignore it you've been
thinking quite a bit from our
conversations earlier about Enron these
days would you care to share your
thoughts with us what the question again
I didn't get it you and I have talked in
recent weeks about shirt interest in the
Enron matter
and you're here to share some thoughts
well this is something that was in a
sense predictable even though wasn't
predicted in the there's a tendency for
the large corporation which in most
cases one shouldn't doubt has a very
effective management but there is a
possibility of a step into air there of
which Enron was the Magnificent example
of a situation in which the operation of
the controls within the corporation that
are required simply get misplaced and
for the most part they do but the
averages they don't get misplaced for
the most part the corporation is a
effective instrument for its own for
first purposes that is why we no longer
speak of capitalism
people who simply have money do not have
the capacity or intelligence to run a
modern corporation and the stockholders
are paid a commonplace amount and
instructed on to register their position
on matters which when they register
their position accept make a proposal
are uniformly ignored and but one
shouldn't doubt that the corporation as
we have it is something that works we
can worry about the extent to which it
intrudes on public policy we should all
worry about the way in which what is
still called the public sector has been
taken over in the military area of power
of the defence industries but it works
and what was your question what I think
I'd like to do is actually invite some
of our audience to join us for a
question would you step forward to the
microphone we'll take just a few
questions here there's one over here and
I believe they're one and two up there
as well I'll have you repeat them I
shall if you want to drink of water
yes professor Galvez my name is News
Herman from the K School of Government
please speak slowly so you touched upon
your relation to Milton Friedman and
Paul Samuelson once said about Friedman
that he has a lot of gifts and talents
his left was but not the gift of the
maybe and I wanted to ask you if you
could elaborate on your personal
relationships and your view of treatment
as an economist a little bit more there
near your views of Milton Friedman as an
economist but what your your views of
Milton Friedman as an economist I view a
mountain but it is very serious citizen
of a very distinguished teacher and the
highest phrase I can give it is
civilized and comfortable and even at
times appealing in spite of error I
think that answers my question Vicki
idea up here we have a question double
failing Arneson on the political
economic visiting there's one one thing
I would like to mention in 1997 I did
predict and wrong with debate in the
debate with Arthur Levitt and
congressman Markey to the tea market has
audacity to use the terminology that I
use then but that's not my question
when I look at American management at
the executive class of last five years I
am astonished by similarity of character
that reminds me Bolshevik Roman Keturah
ninety percent of American executives
think the same way elbow as Bolsheviks
how can we get out of it now this is an
interesting proposition for someone with
a graduate degree from Moscow State
University
your questioner says that in his
observation the managers of the great
American corporations think and behave
like Soviet Bolshevik bureaucrats which
you care to see whether there are
examples to be comparisons to be drawn
out there well I think they there's a
point there that if you're running a
large and complex organization no matter
where it is there will be certain
similarities but you should allow
ideology to improve on that
it is one of the facts of organization
whether it's a Washington bureaucracy a
state government or something in France
or Moscow so to draw conclusions from
some similarities between organizations
is something you should do
well the key similarity is that they are
both trying to steal as much as they can
while it is going on and while they can
thank you very much yes I professor
Galbraith again AC drom I'm a sophomore
undergraduate in the movie 13 days they
talk about how India and I think China
got into a conflict during the Cuban
Missile Crisis I was wondering if you
could comment on any role that you had
in you know alleviating that conflict or
conflicts in India in general when you
were ambassador oh what the student is
referring to just so the audience
understands is that in October 1962
during the Cuban Missile Crisis on
America and the Soviet Union almost
launched a nuclear war what happened was
that India and the Red China also went
to war
professor Galbraith was the United
States ambassador to India at the time
and was given almost carte blush by the
United States government to aid and
support the Indians in this matter I
think the student would like to have you
comment a little bit about this
experience so this was a very intense
time and actually I had someone more
authorities and I knew I had at the time
that film that has recently been
released has Kennedy to miss dismissing
the news of that war by saying all
Galvez is handling that I I so regarded
myself I thought that I was but didn't
know that I had such agreement in
Washington they has n secretary and say
now Alaska Dean Rusk and I were not in
the same wavelength
he was an old-fashioned cold warrior and
I was looking for a peaceful world
and we that brought us into a a
difference of view on quite a few
important matters but that was a minor
episode which both in China and in India
got out of proportion the excitement in
India was accessible
my depth of my concern was accessible
and the reality came one morning about
five o'clock in the morning when news
came that the Chinese had offered a
ceasefire and I got out of bed got the
car and went and saw narrow to urge him
to accept it because in the first place
the conflict was over some real estate
you could only hope would belong to
somebody else and also if I may say so
Indian emotion was getting out of hand
and I have had many pleasant encounters
with Darrow who was a really great
figure of the century but none that I
appreciated so much as that because I
was exactly the person he wanted to see
so then among other things he could
attribute the peace and the sex that
were needed to peace to the United
States he did but that was the
possibility haha while we're on the
subject of State the State Department
you have offered a famous analogy to the
subject of trying to communicate through
the State Department you recall that
it's not the sort of thing that one
centers on at a university but perhaps I
could make one exception drove my time
in India as at other times I had a
considerable direct communication with
Kennedy and the White House and this was
very annoying to the State Department
and they sent a plea from mr. Russell to
the White House asking that I be
instructed to have all my communications
come through the State Department and I
said Kennedy who on the whole I think
like by letters to my telegrams
he wasn't certainly put off by them
wired me I sent a telegram asking what I
thought of it and I told Telegraph banks
that I didn't like it that there was a
particular problem I put it in someone
more rough language the communicating
through the State Department was like
having sexual intercourse through the
blanket
[Applause]
certainly not a routine topic for
university community one more question
one more question yet my name is Marisa
steena Calogero I am a student here
animation fellow at the Kennedy School
I wondered how did you evaluate the
results of the u.s. drug policy as a
macroeconomic level and what would be
from your point of view the policy
options your let me be sure I understand
the question the question is professor
Galbraith views about u.s. drug policy I
think microeconomic level acro economic
level yes whether he would propose any
alternatives
well I take it you're from Colombia of
course I am from Colombia know as to
Colombia
well u.s. drug policy I am I am NOT an
expert on such matters but can I have
the website drugs around just doubts
about the present drug policy as a
notion that it can be controlled by
legal action the same problem that was
faced in my early youth with alcohol and
that we we better revert to education
and taxation
ladies and gentlemen as I promised when
we began this conversation we were going
to talk about some things past but also
some things of the present and of the
future I hope indeed that you have
enjoyed this conversation with professor
Galbraith tonight and I will repeat for
you once again his advice
a man who reads Business Week is lost to
fame one who reads Proust is marked for
greatness so the name Proust I would
also add John Kenneth Galbraith thank
you
[Applause]
John Kenneth Galbraith is taught at
Harvard and Princeton University's been
the editor of Fortune magazine and
written many books on economics he was
interviewed by his biographer Richard
Parker whose book is John Kenneth
Galbraith the making of American
economics it's published by Ferrer
Straus and Giroux online it FS